[Music]
and don't try this at home news
submitted by a fool a fool a man used
the cheese grater to remove a tattoo
only week after getting it done
Oh God DIY man yeah why would you do
that if you watch the tutorial on
YouTube
ouch can you imagine that DIY music that
everyone play how to take off this
tattoo this is what happens was this a
tattoo of like a girl and he's like we
just broke up this [ __ ] [ __ ]
no this hurts but not as much as you
hurt me yeah right
I was the one that says regrets instead
of regrets oh I like you still tattoos
are my favorite looks like a cockroach
I get why you had it removed seven
generation pokey man's it's like what is
that who's just ran out of funding was
lasering really expensive so here's the
thing this happened back in August of
2017 when this guy was 19 years old
laser was invented already um what is
this fancy it is our 14 months yeah
that's an expensive high-tech one yeah
the good ones he probably should have
used the incense
I don't know if it's like burning off
yeah mm-hmm and you picked the incense
and all the things that you could put on
fire or smaller then you can like use it
like a pen so this man's from Argentina
he said that so first of all he had just
gotten the tattoo done but he didn't
like it like how came out like it was
he's very picky so there was a lot about
it that he didn't like look like a
perfect design of whatever he wanted
yeah how does he that picky and
and for those of you that don't all have
to work they spent a lid so then so that
the the tattoo artist has a guide to
follow unless he's doing freehand which
that doesn't look like it should be free
and like they usually just put it on
your skin first before the tattoo in the
mirror could be very one of those polite
people who doesn't want to offend the
tattoo artist so he's like go ahead and
then the guy [ __ ] does it
that's the worst personality Jeff
commutative how to get a tattoo just go
ahead it's fine I'm sure we're off by
the tighter done trait to have as a
person that wants a tattoo yeah that's
really could you laughs one permanent
decision you have it made
what if you're like I want to get
Isaac's face so you so then they [ __ ]
do the mat TV guy instead of Isaac's
face and then you'll be like [ __ ] it
I'll get it anyway so kind to yourself
huh yes if you're so kind to yourself
Jesus well now I am I'm smarter no I
know but hearing you say that I'm like
alms for tech all right all right so
anyway so this guy he said that he just
said like I came out and so he searched
on YouTube how to remove it right so
first he tried he saw the video no he
said the DIY thing oh you're right
tonight
yeah I know you well I said yeah why you
said it's the YouTube video oh did I I
did stop sucking each other's dicks both
knees all right okay just cuz he's
wearing a v-neck in a perfect necklace
doesn't mean I wanted a necklace it's a
chain for a guy what do you call that a
chain but it's got a key on it though
yeah it's still a chain guys the weird
change that's how he unlocks all the
hardener guys don't wear necklaces it's
how I got my tattoos oh I see mmm I
thought is it to the chest he built
around your [ __ ] that's you I do okay
the multi-purpose you never know anyway
that's when initially he tried a pumice
stone but oh my god what's that stupid
like well when you have dead skin on
your feet or whatever you'll it's like
Italy it's a stone
they're [ __ ] heat like he'll callus
all those things it does Corsa sandpaper
so imagine that like a rock that's a
brief for podiatry yeah it's very light
surprisingly it looks like a heavy rock
how come they call it podiatry not just
like foot doc pedal because that is that
no God ha ha ha a tree pod what -
dietary yeah yeah podiatry but she
thought those PE of appeal play bad
that's okay maybe that's like the lab
doctor wrote it away if it doesn't mean
foot doctor no I know but they should
just call it that make it easier on
everybody the other one is a child
molester thank you for the clarification
[Laughter]
go to the pediatrician yeah it's very
important so then this guy here he then
continued on with the grader and said he
said obviously it hurt and he bled a lot
bandaged it a lot and pipe disinfectant
and a week later he went to the hospital
and again a tetanus shot
what is it tetanus shot do it prevent
those from metal in like is the metal
from the cheese grater oh really
I actually don't I don't know but I do
know that people that get cut with
metals that they feel like it could have
possibly been rusted they get it could
be called tetanus and so you just get a
tetanus shot yeah it could be you know
[ __ ] about this [ __ ] science [ __ ] but
what I do know is people will need to
[ __ ] subscribe to us right now dance
because if you want to continue laughing
and we need to beat the algorithms and
we're trying to hit 2 million
subscribers so go ahead and hit that
subscribe button for more laughter but
you didn't hit it yeah did you hit it ok
thank you very much you gotta hit it
dropped it again well you're gonna get
interrupted I mean that's just argument
actually subscribe so I do get
interrupted subscribe thank you you can
interrupt if right now and then and
that's all I got
do you think this person still uses the
cheese grater for cheesy absolutely this
cheese tastes interesting have you guys
done DIY medical things like only only
home remedies I think that have been not
a commonplace but never like go oh LASIK
eye surgery yeah I could do that myself
with a mirror I like getting a lighter
and in burning the cuts that I had
thinking that it was gonna fuse together
like the movies it he likes to scrape
off it or he used to shave off his
pimples with the razor yeah discarded
that's work yeah what no I just don't
like having pimples sunlight so he's
gonna keep getting lucky look how much
you touches his faces and they get
pimples I I have removed several ingrown
toenails what does that look like yeah
and then the nail grows into the side of
it oh that's very common yeah if you get
a pedicure they do that right so I I or
you have to or if it gets really bad you
have to go to a podiatrist and you have
to so yeah so I've removed them several
times and then one time it got so bad
that I just had to go to the doctor oh
yeah
um when he was playing basketball he
[ __ ] up his finger and I think it
stayed like this I had to put a splint
on it with chopsticks and you learned it
from a YouTube video I know I just was
like this seems to be the thing to do
you should make a video explaining how
to do that help others get to get one
chopstick break it in half yeah I'll
tell you but that one actually made
sense I didn't like good she's greater
and try to grate my finger back in place
my cousin made me cut off his goldfishes
dorsal fin cuz it looked like a dick and
it was tightening him know like I was
like how did he make you
not cuz I was like you 11 or something
like that and then he had this one
goldfish right and then the dorsal fin
literally looked like a [ __ ] dick
like a circumcised hard day it's the top
part yeah so the top part it looked like
that and it was just dangling and it had
like you know the part of the rest of
the fin and then he was like hey we need
to do operation because like I don't
know I forgot what what he said to get
me to do it but I said yes and then
that's probably all he said and you were
down yeah probably did you do it in the
water no no you got to we have to grab
the fish take it out and then snip it
and throw it back in yeah but that was
like a home remedy no it was fine but
then we we kind of cleaned it up and
made it made the dick oh it just didn't
have an intimidating dick on it
literally looked like a [ __ ] goldfish
with a dick dangling on top of him
are you trying to justify it yeah I mean
I hey I did some I beautified the fish
okay did youdid you would use scissors
yeah the the small ones from the Swiss
Army knife I was like blunt and [ __ ] too
not small it was sharp it was small and
then the fin was short small so I was
like oh you know perfect size I don't
want you seen anyone with the Swiss Army
knife in a long time I know huh that's
true a little red where he's luring more
white clothes no I just miss seen that I
think this sounds fishy to me
Hey
Miki's here I know did that happen I
don't know the closest thing I've ever
done to that is like piercing myself Oh
like Parent Trap style but with like a
weird object no with like safety pins
would you pierce yeah how'd you know
multiple times then both sides do you
still have holes there no I don't
[ __ ] that's actually pretty intense
that didn't tell you how um I just did
you know that first was like an ice cube
I totally did but I kind of liked the
pop oh god like pain of it I don't I
kind of liked it so like the other times
that I did it I did from men I like the
pain yeah yeah guys like tattoos oh they
don't like the pain hold if I could get
a painless tattoo I would love that
Oh cuz I like the weird kinky [ __ ] but
they they get something else chemically
like that's what we can burn any like
yeah yeah yeah and then I also pierce my
ears like I added two holes on each ear
lobe which I kind of regret cuz they're
all [ __ ] up but I did that do you
think I can parent shop where they ate
the fruit on the bottom and the new
ticket to do so because of the food or
like how do you get enough friction - oh
that's true I mean if it's that that was
kind of surprised you didn't push it so
hard that it went through through when I
got mine he had a metal piece on the
inside and then he stubbed it through oh
so it blocks it yeah exactly
a lot of girls in middle school used to
go to the restroom and then they would
give each other belly piercings I
pressed my girlfriend's ears and then I
tried cuz my girl from wanted to get her
belly I did my belly button that's nice
especially like I didn't do it myself
no Manito rush no I went to like a
tattoo shop and then this is in the
garage no no damn which is in a garage I
just wanted to read the tree you ever
supposed getting her back I know a way
just but it's one design no you
you got a ticket I [ __ ] up my virtue
i'ma jump off the did she like it
yeah did you clean out her [ __ ] caca
inside the belly button first before you
pierced it everybody has baptism middle
school he's like I'm gonna do the full
experience with the safety pin so it was
too thin so she ended up having to get
it again like from somewhere else but I
ended up having like a safety panel
really good for like a minute
what trash your friend
[Music]
[Music]